ANKUR KOTWAL: Hi.
I hope you're ready to see
all the exciting new stuff
we have added in Google
Play services 5.0.
As you already know by now,
Google Play Services rocks.
I'm Ankur Kotwal, and
I've subbed in for Magnus,
as he well, got a
little bit carried away
with the whole rocks theme.
But rest assured,
he's recovering well.
Let's just look at
the latest additions
in Google Play Services 5.0.
It's one of our biggest
releases to date,
including new APIs like Android
Wear, the Dynamic Security
Provider, a major set of
additions to Google Play Games
Services, and the
App Indexing API.
We've also added new APIs for
Google Cast, Google Drive,
Google Wallet, Analytics
and Mobile Ads.
Whew, let's just dive right in.
The first new API for
Google Play Services 5.0
is Android Wearable Services.
With the Data API, we can sync
data between Android Wearables,
and Android phones and tablets.
This can be performed
in three steps.
The first is through messages.
These are uni-directional,
fire and forget,
with delivery not
guaranteed, and are
useful for control signals,
like media playback.
You can use messages to start
intents on the Wearable, too.
Second, you can exchange assets.
These are binary
blogs such as images.
And finally, we have
DataItems, which
are raw byte arrays
for synchronizing
data between these devices.
And next new API is the
Dynamic Security Provider.
Think of this as
providing an SSL library
in Google Play Services.
The advantage of including
this in Google Play Services
is that the Dynamic Security
Provider will be updated along
with Google Play
Services, keeping
the security fixes up-to-date.
Google Play Games Services
is itself not a new API,
but this time, it has
so many new features
that we're celebrating
it like a new API.
We've now added quests,
a new set of APIs
to run time-based
events for players,
and rewards for completing them.
To do this, developers
send game activity data
to the quest service whenever
a player successfully wins
a level, stops an alien, or
saves a rare black sheep.
This tells quests what's
going on in the game,
and developers can use that game
activity to create new quests.
By running quests
on a regular basis,
developers can create an
unlimited number of new player
experiences to drive
re-engagement and retention.
Saved Games is a
new snapshot API,
so developers can store a
player's game progress for use
across many screens, along with
a cover image, description,
and the time played.
Players never need
to complete level
one again by having their
progress stored with Google,
and can see where they left
off when developers attach
a cover image and description.
Game Profile collects
a user's achievements,
and rewards them with
experience points.
To activate experience
points, you only
need to confirm point
distribution in the Google Play
developer console.
In fact, you don't even
need to update your games
to activate experience points.
These sets of features are going
to drive up gamer engagement,
whilst allowing them to pick
up a game on their phone,
and continue it on their tablet.
Maybe soon, gamers
could be interacting
on their Android Wearables, too.
Exciting times ahead.
The App Indexing API
provides a way for developers
to notify Google
about deep links
in their native
mobile applications,
and drive additional
user engagement.
Integrating with
the App Indexing API
allows the Google Search app
to serve your app's history
to users as instant
search suggestions,
providing fast and easy
access to those inner pages
in your app.
The deep links reported using
the Apps Indexing API are also
used by Google to index
your app's content,
and surface them as deep links
to the Google search results.
How awesome is that?
Now let's look at updates
to existing APIs starting
with Google Cast, which now has
media tracks that enable closed
caption support for Chromecast.
Finally, I can watch my
TV shows late at night
with the volume
low, and still know
what's happening on screen.
I love captions.
The Google Drive API is getting
very useful enhancements.
Query results can be sorted.
Folders can now be
created offline,
and the file picker can
be filtered by mime type.
Building great apps with the
Google Drive storage backend
has never been easier.
With all these awesome
APIs, your apps
are going to go where
they've never been before.
So, what should we look at next?
Ah, yes, let's dive into ways
that we can drive monetization.
And now ladies and gentleman,
here is my new favorite
Wallet API, Save card to Google.
Wallet objects from Google
take physical objects,
like loyalty cards and
offers from your wallet,
and store it in the cloud.
When a user clicks the
Save card to Google button,
the offer gets
saved, and shows up
in the user's Google Wallet app.
And here's the best part.
Geo-fenced in-store
notifications
prompt the user to show
and scan digital cards
at point-of-sales terminals,
driving higher redemption.
This also frees the
user from having
to carry around offers
and loyalty cards,
and provides a great
purchasing experience.
In fact, merchants are
happier because they
get increased offer
proliferation.
Customers are
happier because they
don't need to carry so many
of their loyalty cards.
And developers are happier
for connecting these consumers
to merchants.
Google Analytics has
introduced Enhanced Ecommerce,
which provides visibility into
the full customer journey.
Adding the ability to measure
product impressions, product
clicks, view product
details, adding a product
to shopping cart, initiating
a checkout process,
internal promotions,
transactions, and refunds.
Together they help users
to gain deeper insights
into the performance
of their business,
including how far users progress
through that shopping funnel,
and where they're abandoning
in the purchasing process.
Enhanced Ecommerce allows users
to analyze the effectiveness
of their marketing and
merchandising effort,
including the impact of
internal promotions, coupons,
and affiliate
marketing programs.
Google Mobile Ads are a great
way to monetize your apps,
and with Google
Play Services 5.0,
you now have access to
better in-app purchase ads.
We've also made improvements to
the Play Store in-app purchase
API client, so it requires
less effort to integrate.
Well folks, Google Play
Services 5.0 is huge
and it's rolled out
to devices everywhere.
So now it's your turn.
Show us what you can build
with these awesome APIs.